[Aplausos]
se me agrandó el aula veo y está lleno
de humanos
es un hecho que hubo humanos mucho antes
que hubiera historia hace casi 200.000
años en la época de las cavernas
imaginen un poquito penumbra frío
miedo mucho miedo
había unos seres muy parecidos a
nosotros
peligrosamente parecidos diría yo que
fueron los únicos
capaces de diferenciarse del resto de
las especies con las que convivía
hubo un momento en que la evolución
los despegó del resto
esa evolución fue gracias a que fueron
capaces de desarrollar nuevas formas de
pensar y nuevas formas de comunicarse
los homo sapiens
necesitaban estar alertas
vigilantes
entender y comprender su entorno porque
necesitaban protegerse por eso
desarrollaron lazos muy fuertes y
comunidades capaces de protegerlos hace
casi 200.000 años
los humanos de hoy hablamos con mi amigo
murat de estambul casi sin demora y sin
costo
sabemos que comen y qué marca de vino
toman muchos de nuestros amigos que si
vemos por la calle nos saludamos
sabemos de fiestas de viajes de amores
de otra gente que tampoco conocemos
tenemos tanta tanta información y sin
embargo tan poca comunicación
hace unos meses creo que la mayoría de
nosotros recibimos en nuestros celulares
una imagen de una chica
recostada en el pasillo de un hospital
estaba recostado sobre su mochila y
tenía un barbijo puesto
alguien desde su celular tomó esa foto
horas después nos enteramos de que esa
chica muy cerca de aquí fallecía por
kobe por falta de la atención adecuada
hubiera pasado eso en la época de las
cavernas
qué nos pasa
vivimos en un mundo instantáneo
accesible
hipercomunicado
tenemos herramientas tecnológicas que
nos permiten ver más flacos más jóvenes
más viejos con orejas de conejo con
orejas de elefante
tenemos tecnología que nos permite
vernos dentro de nosotros mismos
resonancias tomografías
radiografías sin embargo ninguna de
estas aplicaciones o tecnologías nos
permite vernos a nosotros mismos
qué nos pasa
estamos constantemente buscando
nuevas experiencias que nos movilicen
que nos hagan sentir
mediante un satélite
hacemos miles y miles de contactos
pero sin el tacto
estamos viviendo una época en que la
soledad nunca fue tan grande y la
comunicación más vacía
en la larga historia de la humanidad
fuimos capaces de ser creativos
sensibles
inteligentes
aprendimos a dejar a desarrollar la
astronomía la matemática la física la
medicina las artes
contamos con toda la tecnología
sin embargo que nos pasa
nuestros ancestros
aquellos homo sapiens no podían
permitirse la indiferencia tenían que
sobrevivir tenían que cuidarse unos a
otros
tenían que formar comunidades para
sobrevivir
nosotros hoy buscamos experiencias
y eso me hace acordar a cuando encontré
a mi amiga en el shopping con los
auriculares puestos
tomando un helado de chocolate buscando
una playlist que le gustaba y que no
encontraba manteniendo tres
conversaciones al mismo tiempo
me equivoqué perdón esto no era para
este chat
desconexión total del ruido externo del
calor del sabor del chocolate de las
conversaciones del placer de la música
estamos
sistemáticamente alejándonos de nosotros
mismos
de nuestros sentidos
de nuestro entorno
de nuestro propio cuerpo
porque el relacionarnos con otros nos
lleva a invertir tiempo y esfuerzo
físico que no estamos destinados no
estamos decididos a dar
mi amigo pedro me dice una vez cuando me
ve comiendo unas galletas de arroz de
esas que todos conocemos
y si sabéis qué es lo bueno de eso
que cuando las terminas de comer si te
quedas con hambre seguís con la caja y
ni siquiera te das cuenta
no me van a decir que no
esas son las clases de experiencias es
casi lo mismo
fuimos capaces de tantas cosas fuimos
capaces de sobrevivir de cuidarnos sin
embargo ahora que nos pasa
fuimos capaces de hablar de la ficción
de lo que no se ve
capaces de entender un gesto una mirada
un abrazo de aprender a confiar o no en
alguien
hablamos de los dioses hablamos del amor
hablamos de la amistad y hablamos de la
paz
por eso si fuimos capaces de tanto y
llegamos hasta acá que nos pasa
quiero dejarles un desafío simple no
para que sea tarea del hogar sino que
busquen
algún humano de su especie es cercano
cotidiano
que lo miren
y se pregunten cómo está
cómo se siente
qué pasa por su cabeza
en estos momentos
y las cosas que me unen o no a él
y lo más importante
preguntarnos en el caso que debamos
sobrevivir juntos en ese momento
terrible en que uno tiene que decidir y
ponerse de acuerdo
en el caso de que debamos sobrevivir
juntos
podremos comunicarnos
gracias
[Aplausos]